في تطورات التصعيد الاسرائيلي بالضفه
الغربيه اقتحمت قوات كبيره من جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مدينه الخليل جنوبي
الضفه الغربيه وتحاصر منطقه راس الجوره
ودائره السير عند المدخل الشمالي للمدينه
ودهمت منزل الشهيد عبد القادر القواسمي
تمهيدا لهدمه بتهمه تنفيذه والشهيدين نصر
الله القواسمي وحسن قفيشه عمليه النفق
راموت في مدينه القدس التي اسفرت عن مقتل
جندي اسرائيلي واصابه سبعه اخرين في
نوفمبر تشرين الثاني من العام
الماضي من الخليل ينضم الينا مراسل
الجزيره منتصر نصار منتصر كيف تبدو
الاوضاع نعم السي بالفعل نحن نتواجد هنا
عند المدخل الشمالي لمدينه الخليل وتحديدا
في منطقه دائره السير هذا المكان الذي
سمحت لنا فيه قوات الاحتلال ان نتواجد فيه
خلفنا مباشره في هذا الطريق المدخل المؤدي
الى منزل الشهيد نصر الله القواسمه
والشهيد عبد القادر القواسمه والشهيد حسن
قفيشه الذين نفذوا عمليه اطلاق نار عند
حاجز النفق في بيت لحم في السادس عشر من
نوفمبر الماضي هذه العمليه اسفرت عن مقتل
جندي اسرائيل واصابه سبعه اخرين قبل حوالي
ساعه ونصف الى ساعتين من الان داهمت قوات
الاحتلال هذه المنطقه الان و قبل قليل من
خروجنا معكم على الهواء وردنا ان هناك
تعزيزات عسكريه كبيره دخلت الى المنطقه من
جهه فرش الهواء وبئر المحجر عدد كبير من
الاليات العسكريه ترافقها جرافه كبيره وهي
في طريقها تحديدا الى منزل الشهيد عبد
القادر القواسمه هنا المواطنون تجمعوا
بالعشرات يراقبون ما يجري قوات الاحتلال
قامت
باخراج كل المركبات التي تواجدت عند
الدخله المؤديه الى منزل الشيخ عبد القادر
القواسمه و قامت باخلاء العمارات السكنيه
والمنازل المجاوره والمحيط لمنازل الشهداء
الثلاثه منازل الشهداء الثلاثه تقع في
مربع ضيق وهي على مقربه من بعضها البعض في
منطقه دائره السير وحتى هذه اللحظه لا
يتوفر لدينا اي معلومات ما اذا كانت النيه
هدم المنازل الثلاثه او او هدم احد هذه
المنازل او منزلين لكن قوات الاحتلال كما
ذكرنا متواجده باعداد كبيره جدا قبل
ساعتين اقتحمت الخليل من اكثر من مدخل
اغلقت هذا المكان الذي نتواجد فيها وهذا
الشارع تحديدا وهو الشارع يعني نحن على
بعد امتار قليله من منزل الشهيد نصر الله
القواسمي تحديدا يليه مباشره منزل الشهيد
عبد القادر القواسمي قوات الاحتلال كانت
اخطرت عوائل الشهداء الثلاثه بهدم منازلهم
وخلال الاسبوعين الماضيين اكثر من مره
قوات الاحتلال داهمت المنازل وقامت
بالتقاط الصور واخذ قياسات هذه المنازل
وقامت بابلاغ ايضا السكان القريبين من هذه
ال المنازل بنيتها الهدم وبالفعل نحن امام
مشهد الهدم هذه الليله في مدينه الخليل
الحديث عن ثلاثه منازل مختره بالهدم
واليات كبيره تداهم المنطقه جرافتين
عسكريتين في المكان اضافه الى عدد من
الماكينات الخاصه بت تفجير المنازل كنا
شاهدناها محمله بشاحنات وهي في طريقها الى
منزل الشهداء القواسمه و قفيشه ولا تزال
قوات الاحتلال تتواجد حتى هذه اللحظه في
المنطقه قبل قليل ايضا سمعنا اصوات اطلاق
قنابل صوت وقنابل غاز سام مسيل الدموع
ايضا اطلقتها قوات الاحتلال باتجاه الشبان
المتواجدين في هذه المنطقه وفي هذا المكان
المشهد هنا السي متوتر حتى هذه اللحظه
ونحن على الاقل امام ساعات طويله هذه
الليله هنا في مدينه الخليل حيث ان العاده
جرت ان تفجير المنازل ياخذ وقتا طويلا
عندما كانت تقتحم قوات الاحتلال الخليل من
اجل تفجير احد المنازل يستغرق الامر حتى
ساعات الصباح الاولى ما بالك عندما نتحدث
عن ثلاثه منازل مختره بالهدم